I mean there is a vacuum of American
leadership
on the world stage today and and the
antidote here is American engagement
American leadership and American
strength
[Music]
hello everyone watching and listening
today I'm speaking with former vice
president and now 2024 presidential
candidate Mike Pence
we discussed U.S government overreach
and economic matters when it should be
playing referee
the indoctrination of our youngest
citizens
how parents are being purposefully
alienated from their children via
ideological capture the realistic Way
Forward on the Russia Ukraine front
the loss of international respect due to
our current Administration
and how we might finally stabilize a
nation wrought with cultural Warfare
it's very good to have you on this
podcast Mr Vice President it's uh it's
quite the honor as a matter of fact I
guess that's actually my first question
you know this having presidential
candidates sit down and do long-form
podcasts like this is it's a new it's
new uh like it's one year new really so
what made you decide to take the risk
let's say or take or grab the advantage
or the opportunity to do a podcast with
me
well Jordan just thanks for having me on
uh you know uh uh I've been admirer of
yours for a number of years
um uh was uh was turned onto your work
by my by my kids a few of whom you met
out on the road and on the trail and so
it's uh it's a joy to be with you
um look I I I the decision to run for
the highest office in the land uh is is
one that no American would ever take
lightly and my family and I have given
great thought great prayer and
deliberation
to this question uh over the last two
years
and frankly ultimately it comes down to
two things number one it's the
Privileges that we've had to serve the
experiences that we've developed uh I
was not only vice president serving
America at home and abroad but I was
also a governor of a successful state in
Indiana where we cut taxes and expanded
educational choice and before that for
12 years I was a leader of of house
conservatives uh in uh the Congress of
the United States and uh the the sum
total of that 20 years of experience uh
gives us the confidence that if we were
given the privilege of serving as
president of the United States that that
we'd be prepared we prepared to bring
this country back which leads me to the
second reason why we should decided to
run and that was uh uh you know I think
this country's in a lot of trouble
I mean as I've traveled around the
country over the last two years it's
it's clear to me that Joe Biden and the
radical left have weakened America at
home and abroad uh and and we need new
leadership and I believe in the
Republican party and uh in the White
House that'll set this country back on a
path uh of a strong National Defense of
limited government of a commitment to
freedom and to Traditional Values and uh
and it's in response to that it's in the
it's in the belief on which on which I
was raised I don't know if it made it in
12 rules but it's an old rule in my life
that to whom much is given much will be
required and my family and I have been
given much we've been given incredible
privileges and opportunities to lead and
when we when we look at the challenges
facing our country today we just felt we
had a duty to step forward we do so with
great enthusiasm and we've been very
humbled at the outpouring of support
that we've received Mike
pence2024.com and what we've heard out
on the road already since we announced a
little earlier this week in the great
state of Iowa
so we've met twice before we met in
Washington I met you and your wife and
then we talked for about an hour and a
half at one point about about a year ago
I believe we did and I walked away from
that thinking
if uh if Mike Pence was president
we might see a return to something like
blessed normality and that's a
compliment you know because I think the
times when when politics when politics
gets radically interesting something has
gone dreadfully wrong like I'd rather
see something approximating a sane in
normative Administration than a
continual exciting like even hyper
charismatic battle I think that's a sign
of bad times and so
let me let me let me delve into that a
little bit you just outlined your
qualifications well I'm very humbled by
those words and you know it actually
makes me think of uh another time maybe
a century ago and I'm not someone that
looks backwards or wants to turn the
clock back we could stop that
conversation uh with anyone else now
but you know there was there was a
season after World War one where uh uh a
republican ticket stepped forward
literally their message was a return to
normalcy
and I I get a sense that the American
people would like to get back to the
policies that were Advanced under a
president I deeply admire which was
President Calvin Coolidge uh he was
someone that balanced budgets he cut
taxes he oversaw an incredible time of
American Prosperity but at the core of
his philosophy
was an often quoted Calvin Coolidge
statement that
the business of America is business
and and by that he he meant the business
of America is not the government itself
that that the the federal government
should not or the white house should not
be the center of American life and they
actually Calvin Coolidge restraint and
his his instinctive conservatism uh uh
really set a tone that allowed for a
period of incredible innovation in the
country that's where we heard all the
incredible stories about progress and in
manufacturing and Industry and uh and
and I I hold I hold to the view that uh
that it's the free market it's free
enterprise that's where the energy comes
from I grew up in a small business
family I I know who makes this country
go every day and the government should
be playing the role of of the referee of
the private sector uh and and not at
Center Court with all the attention
focus there
so let me let me touch on something else
that you you touched on earlier you
talked about the radical left now I
spent some time working with Democrats
and I just interviewed Robert F Kennedy
and I asked him the same question that
I've asked every Democrat I've met in
the last five years and the question I
asked was when does the left go too far
and I believe this to be true that none
of the Democrats that I've spoken with
and we spoke in good faith and we had
serious conversations we're able to
we're willing to answer that question
now you made a comment about the radical
left and so when do you think the left
goes too far and
and what would you what do you think if
they are going too far those who are on
the far left like how do you identify
that what do you think what do you think
might be what's the appropriate response
to that
well look I've I've been at this a while
um and uh
but but I never thought I'd live to see
the day that that socialism was the
animating economic philosophy of one of
America's two major political parties
you know I like to say to people uh Joe
Biden won the nomination of his party in
2020 but uh but Bernie Sanders won the
party I mean all the policies that
you've seen flowing uh out of the
democratic party and out of the Biden
Administration are driven by
european-style socialism and welfare
state policies and that's too far I mean
as I said this we're we're a nation that
was that was founded on the
constitutional principles of a limited
federal government a free enterprise
free market private property all of
those things have been a Wellspring
along with our faith our family is a
foundation of of of of of creating the
strongest and freest most prosperous
nation in the history of the world uh by
far and so that to me is a go too far
but I will tell you this whole issue of
uh of of of of
advancing through critical race theory
in our schools literally teaching our
kids
uh to uh uh to to
judge judge their peers not by the
content of their character
but by the color of their skin the
opposite of the vision of the Reverend
Dr Martin Luther King Jr and then beyond
that the radical gender ideology that is
afoot uh in our schools and our
universities and in the culture today I
think uh I I think has uh uh literally
shocked the conscience of many parents
uh who who might never identify with uh
with a mainstream conservative
philosophies that we share and
Traditional Values that we share Jordan
but they find themselves struck I mean I
my foundation in Washington DC uh
actually weighed in on a federal lawsuit
the Lenmar Community Schools in Iowa
require students to bring in a
permission slip from their parents to
get a Tylenol
uh but under the school policy a student
could get a gender transition plan from
the health department at that high
school without ever informing their
parents and as I said when we went to
Iowa and spoke about it that's not just
bad policy that's crazy and I see
parents parents rights groups are rising
up all over the country uh and and
pushing back on uh on the radical left
uh effort to indoctrinate our kids uh
about our history uh and and and and
also that this whole business of of uh
of trying to trying to communicate this
radical gender ideology I think it's I
think it's it's a Wellspring of support
pushing back on that I think you're
going to see see that show up in 2024.
well two things on that I would say the
first it was yesterday you know the
National Health Service of the UK
declared that they would no longer allow
the use of puberty blockers except in re
for children except in research
situations and so I believe it's the UK
Finland Norway Sweden and Holland have
all and Holland is where this started by
the way the Netherlands
they're dropping the gender affirming
model of care and so the second thing is
um
yeah this is a question I've been trying
to put forward to Republicans
particularly at the level of the
governor so
you know the faculties of Education in
the United States and in Canada have a
hammer lock on teacher certification
and public education eats up about 50
percent of the state budgets now I know
this isn't a federal issue precisely but
I can't understand for the life of me
why Republicans haven't noticed that by
allowing the depart or the the faculties
of Education which are among the most
corrupt
institutions in higher education by
allowing them to maintain their
hammerlock on teacher certification
which they've done nothing to deserve
they're essentially handing over half
the state budgets to the worst students
at the universities who are the most
ideologically adult who have direct
contact with children so I mean from a
strategic perspective this seems to me
to be a very bad idea and you know it's
hard to push back against a system of
ideas like the like the woke
Congregation of ideas without also
stepping into sensorial territory you
know which is the threat I suppose to
some degree with regard to what's
happening in Florida when you when you
think about strategy to forestall the
narcissistic Progressive agenda what
sort of strategies do you have in mind
that could be employed at the federal
level
well first I I'm you know I'm heartened
to hear the progress in other countries
protecting kids
uh from uh from chemical or surgical
gender transition I strongly support
efforts in my home state of Indiana and
around the country uh to uh prohibit uh
gender transition chemical or surgical
treatment for children under the age of
18. I'd look at uh I'm I I'm libertarian
enough to say if you're an adult you
live while you live uh you know I may
not agree with decisions you make but
we'll love you and and uh uh love our
neighbor as ourselves as my faith
requires right but Live and Let Live but
for our kids uh absolutely not we've got
to take a strong stand I did a town hall
on CNN not long ago and the host of the
show uh insisted on asking me I think
about five times in a row about why I
took such a strong stand on that and I
said look I'm standing here not just as
a former vice president and a governor
I'm a dad I'm a grandfather this is
really about protecting our kids from
making decisions decisions early in
their lives but when they're not
equipped to make them there's a reason
we don't let kids drive cars until
they're 16 and uh and you know you you
can't even get a tattoo under the age of
18 and my home state so that
this principle of protecting kids from
irreversible choices uh and and you know
and have spoken more eloquently than
maybe anyone else about the deleterious
effects now go back to your question
because I think it's the fundamental
question uh and that is so how do we
push back and I will tell you I believe
that giving parents the ability to
choose where their children go to school
public private parochial or home school
is the cure for what ales education in
America I think your point about teacher
certification is a profound one but I'm
very struck by the fact that someone who
I'm sure you respect a great deal uh in
fact a couple a Milton and Rose Friedman
maybe one of the great uh free market
economic minds of the last century
he left his entire state
to a foundation to promote one idea and
that was educational choice
because Milton Friedman said our form of
government will not survive without an
educated citizenry and that the only
Power
strong enough
to to transform and renew American
education is the free market it's a very
simple idea I'm proud to say the state
of Indiana Jordan was one of the
Pioneers in educational choice we had we
were home to the very first privately
funded School voucher program in the
country that's been replicated all over
the country for decades but when I was
governor we had a we had a small
educational Choice program I doubled it
I made it the largest in the country but
we just and I don't know if if the
viewers and listeners of your podcast
know this but we really turned a corner
very recently in this debate when the
State of Arizona
uh under Governor Doug Ducey in in the
last year in office
passed the first ever Universal school
choice program in the country the state
of Indiana has essentially followed
about 98 of people of our state now have
educational Choice Iowa has followed
other states are following and I I would
submit to you that whether we're talking
about the radical uh left's agenda in
our schools whether it's critical race
Theory woke politics or some of the
profound issues in higher education that
you're speaking about you give parents
the ability to choose where their kids
go to school to be able to take their
business down the street and find a
school uh that that you know it gives
them a more classical education uh that
you know uh my school teacher wife would
tell you that teaches phonics to kids
I mean I mean parents will go shopping
they will I I don't I believe what
wherever people are on that ladder of
success in America everybody loves their
kids everybody loves their grandkids and
uh and you give them the power to choose
where their kids go to school and uh
will turn education around in America
faster than you could imagine
do you ever read the fine print that
appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode it says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school or your internet
service provider how can they even call
it incognito to really stop people from
seeing the sites you visit you need to
do what we do and use expressvpn think
about all the times you've used Wi-Fi at
a coffee shop or a hotel without
expressvpn every site you visit could be
logged by the Admin of that Network and
that's still true even when you're in
incognito mode your home internet
provider can also see and record your
browsing data and in the US they're
legally allowed to sell that data to
advertisers
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
of your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
that your private online activity stays
just that private expressvpn works on
all of your devices and is super easy to
use the app has one button you tap it to
connect and your browsing activity is
secure from prying eyes so stop letting
strangers invade your online privacy by
visiting expressvpn.com Jordan that's
exp r e s s vpn.com Jordan and get three
extra months free
expressvpn.com Jordan
so I I have a question specific question
about that um when I was talking to one
of my wiser friends about the issue of
school choice the objection he raised
and I wasn't really sure what to make of
it was that if you provide parents with
Choice what you end up is a with is a
public school system that has the worst
teachers and the students who are most
disaffected and alienated from their
parents and so he felt that there was an
element of that that would be disastrous
for the kids who were in the worst shape
with regards to parents and future
opportunity has what's the experience of
Indiana and the other states that have
moved in the direction of school choice
what has that taught you were revealed
in that regard
well I used to say you know I I long
before I held office for 20 years I had
a talk radio show we used to talk a lot
about this and I I grew up in a stand in
a family that ran gas stations I
actually worked for five years helped
pave my way through college
uh pumping gas and uh so I would kind of
break it down this way I'd say to people
look if there's only one gas station in
town
uh and you had to buy your gas there
how clean do you think the men's room
would be
right I mean so it's competition
competition for customers makes
everybody better and I will tell you our
experience in Indiana has been that our
public schools have gotten better they
have they have stepped into that
competition and improved uh once once
parents become empowered we've seen
we've seen parents in Indiana over the
decades choose another public school
over the public school that's failing
them and I will tell you it's it's
always been impressive to me
that from very early on
uh the African-American community in
this country
has been a a a a generation ahead of the
rest of the country in support uh for
educational Choice Jordan and literally
literally back in the 1990s in Indiana
when the when the when the overall
population even in a state that was
promoting school choice we'd maybe get
50 55 of Hoosiers that would support
allowing parents to choose where the
kids go to school the number in the
African-American community in our state
was closer to 70 to 75 percent and and
you and I know why it's because of the
minority communities in many of our
major cities their kids are relegated to
some of the the most failing and
dangerous schools in the country those
parents know they said give me the
choice they've taken that choice and and
it isn't and a lot of times they go to
the they go to this to the school this
in their neighborhood they go to the
little cat Catholic school that's just
down around the corner and it engages
parents I've heard the argument your
friend made and I look I I I don't mean
to demean it but it's just not been our
experience I mean literally I think of
uh you know John F Kennedy back when he
talked about cutting taxes across the
board including the capital gains tax
and he said you know a rising tide lifts
all boats you know you create
competition in education in America as
we have in Indiana and states around the
country are doing uh all the schools get
better and as someone who's married to a
woman that taught for 15 years in a
public school 15 years in a Christian
School I could tell you firsthand
there's a there's an overwhelming
majority that are teaching in our Public
Schools or dedicated public servants men
and women that care deeply it's just the
management not being responsive pushing
down some sort of a liberal agenda
watering down some of the fundamentals
and and criteria for a good education I
think that washes away uh in in the in
through the force of the free market I
really do
so I feel obligated to warn you that
according to the dictates of YouTube
apparently we've both now engaged in
hate speech and the incitement of
violence
so I had a YouTube video taken off my
channel yesterday an interview with
Helen Joyce who wrote who who wrote a
book on on trans minor surgery
phenomenon and so I'm sure we've broken
the YouTube rules already in this
discussion so it'll be interesting to
see what they do as a consequence of
that so all right so you think that that
you think that the experience in Indiana
has shown that
because of the introduction of
competition everybody benefits and you
said in particular perhaps black
students and their parents okay so
that's that's a good that's a good uh
that's a good for you in that direction
let me ask you a couple of questions in
a different direction if you don't mind
um I think often at the moment that
we're all fiddling while Rome Burns
because possibly because of the
situation in Russia and Ukraine and you
know and one of the things that I found
heartening let's say about the Trump
presidency where you served as vice
president was that there were four years
without a major war and your
Administration or that Administration
also Advanced the Abraham Accords which
was a major move in the direction of
Peace in the Middle East and now we have
this war percolating away madly
between Russia Ukraine and it's really a
proxy war in many ways for the west and
Russia and you know it doesn't it
doesn't look very good to me and so if
you became president first of all what
do you think the way forward is on that
front I know the Hawks are saying the
Hawks on the Republican side in
particular and I think this is also true
in the Democrat side are taking this as
an opportunity to demolish Russia's
conventional forces and to take them
permanently out as a conventional enemy
let's say now the problem I see in that
is that when you push someone as
powerful as Russia into a corner when
they're nuclear armed and their
conventional forces are weak that that
loosens the finger on the nuclear
trigger and it also doesn't seem to me
that given how dependent we are on
Russia and Ukraine for food and and for
energy that we can weakening both of
those countries on something
approximating a permanent basis strikes
me as as reasonable long-term policy so
what do you think the danger is on the
Russia Ukraine front and what would your
Administration what steps would your
Administration take in that direction
well I'm someone that believes that
America is the leader of the Free World
we're the Arsenal democracy
in 1985 Ronald Reagan in a State of the
Union Address articulated what came to
be known as the Reagan Doctrine which
essentially said it'll be the policy of
the United States that if you're willing
to fight the Communists in your country
we'll give you the means to fight them
there so we don't have to fight them
here
uh and it was part and parcel of of what
ultimately brought down the Soviet Union
and and I I believe that that wisdom is
still true today uh that uh Ukraine is
uh not our war but freedom is our fight
now I I know there I know there are
people in the presidential contest in my
party who have uh uh who who have uh
spoke admiringly of uh of Vladimir
Putin's genius others have said that
it's simply a territorial dispute it
said well I can tell you I know the
difference between a genius and a war
criminal like
um and uh I know the difference between
a territorial dispute and a Russian
invasion
I mean what's happening in Ukraine today
is an unprovoked invasion that is
claiming hundreds of thousands of lives
and I believe it's incumbent on the
United States of America continue to
lead the West uh and provide the
Ukrainian military what they need to
repel the Russian invasion and reclaim
their sovereignty now I I I believe
that's the right thing to do my wife and
I Jordan about a year ago were visiting
a Christian relief group in Poland that
was assisting refugees and when we
arrived we were told that we were
cleared to go into Ukraine this was a
month after hostilities had begun and we
went 10 miles across the border to a
refugee Center
and Jordan I I say this with a broken
heart I saw things uh I thought I'd
never see other than in black and white
films uh from 75 years ago I mean they
were all crowds of all women of every
age
children of every age carrying
everything that could carry on their
backs literally fleeing uh this this uh
this unconscionable Russian invasion and
so I I think we have an obligation to be
there but I also want to say to you I
think it's in our national interests
there's others have said that it's not I
I've met Vladimir Putin
um I I believe it was no coincidence
that uh ours was the only Administration
uh in the 21st century where Putin did
not attempt to redraw International
Lines by force I mean he rolled the
tanks into the country of Georgia under
the Bush Administration of course took
Crimea under the Obama Administration
and now he's rolled across the border
Ukraine I think the reason he did didn't
do that during our years was because
we have the largest uh increase in
military spending uh in more than a
generation uh we unleashed our military
against Isis and they took them down
without firing a shot we actually took
down a hundred Uh Russian mercenaries in
a conflict in Syria without one American
casually we shut down the nordstream 2
pipeline for all of uh of the uh
rhetorical efforts by my old running
mate to a reopened dialogue with Russia
we were very tough on Russia and we were
willing to use American military force
to defend our interest and defend our
allies around the world and I think that
kept Russia in check so uh I think this
is a moment that needs to be met with
American strength and I'm going to
continue to advocate for that I also
think at the end of the day
if if Russia was able to overrun Ukraine
it in my judgment it would not be long
before the Russian military
uh was crossing a border where we would
have to send uh troops like like my son
the Marine my son-in-law uh the Navy
pilot uh he crosses into a NATO Ally
Then we're involved we we should not
ever send American troops into Ukraine
we should we should hasten the delivery
of military equipment uh and give them
the ability to defend themselves but I
think stopping Russia there is also in
the interest of the United States and it
sends it it sends a deafening message to
China lastly Jordan it sends a deafening
message to China we repel we give
Ukraine the ability to repel the Russian
invasion then I I have no doubt in my
mind that President XI who I've also met
and spoken to privately uh I think I
think he will uh he'll get more
instruction from that uh regarding uh
his potential military Ambitions in the
Asia Pacific than than anything else
that we could do I was just informed
your team team wants 30 seconds to speak
with you my team doesn't need me oh hi
oh it's just my wife said hi
oh
come on well that's that's a good step
over that's a good emergency yeah
stick your head you can see if you look
at the screen Karen pants Jordan
Peterson hello
nice to see again yeah nice to see you
hi good thank you for Lending us your
husband for an hour anyway hello
I told him the kids are big fans that's
how we go yeah
so let me ask you then more specifically
if the war in Russia plays out the way
that would be most beneficial to the
West what what's your vision for victory
and the cessation of conflict what is it
do you suppose that Russia has to leave
on the table or bring to the table in
order to bring this war to a halt yeah I
just think I think we have to support
the Ukraine military until they repel
this Russian invasion uh from across
their borders I don't now I'll I'll
defer to uh president zielinski and uh
the government in Ukraine if they have a
different view but I think I I think
that giving them the means to push
Russia out
uh from uh where it commenced this
Invasion uh is absolutely essential to
sending to sending a message to The
Wider World
um that uh that America is the leader of
the Free World and we'll support those
that are standing for their freedom and
sovereignty
and do you think that would mean that
the Russians would have to abandon the
territory they took on on the East and
also what about the situation in Crimea
what do you see the post-war I don't
understand exactly what might constitute
the post-war boundaries of Ukraine yeah
well I think if if things worked out as
well as they could well I again I would
leave that question
uh which predated our Administration uh
to to the Ukrainian government
um uh but with regard to this this
Invasion this incursion the donbos
region I I just don't think we can
tolerate it and let me also say
um President Biden said in the State of
the Union Address that we're there as
long as it takes uh Jordan it shouldn't
take that long
we're the arsenal of democracy we've
been dragging our feet on giving them
equipment uh we promised from 33 Abrams
Tanks uh all the way back in January
they still don't have them we've been
dragging our feet on on giving them
aircraft uh you know it was our
Administration that that that started
back providing uh military uh resources
to Ukraine the Obama Biden
administration had refused to provide
any military resources they were they
were sending uh blankets and MREs we
came in we we provided them Javelin
missiles we provided them resources that
they were able to use in this fight uh
over the four years of our
Administration and uh uh the white
Administration immediately ended that
when they came in but at the initiation
of hostilities started to catch up but I
want to be clear all of your viewers and
and listeners Joe Biden has been slow on
the uptake and I think that frankly the
disasters with all if Afghanistan
created the conditions that embolden the
enemies of Freedom now Vladimir Putin is
the one that's responsible for this
unconscionable Invasion but I have no
doubt in my mind that that disastrous
withdrawal in Afghanistan emboldened him
to move and uh and and I I I honestly
believe that it's been the failed
policies of the Biden Administration uh
that are contributing to not only war in
Eastern Europe Chinese provocations but
but for heaven's sakes Jordan after we
achieved uh the first peace Accord in
nearly 30 years in the Middle East uh
the bite Administration did nothing to
build on the Abraham Accords sent says
sent ambiguous signals to Israel about
our support and then stood and then
stood idly by
while China negotiated a treaty between
Iran and Saudi Arabia I mean there's a
vacuum of American leadership uh on the
world stage today and and the antidote
here is American engagement American
leadership in American strength it also
it's also worth folks that are looking
on knowing
the Biden Administration has been busy
cutting military spending since day one
and uh the only thing positive about
that that gigantic supplemental build
that passed at the end of the last
Congress was that it caught up on
military budget cuts
that the Biden administration had been
advancing but with this new debt ceiling
deal people deserve to know that uh
after you net out inflation it's got a
one percent cotton military spending
China's floating a new Battleship every
month and has doubled its military
budget in the last 15 years and here we
have an Administration that is cutting
military spending all the while they're
they're carrying that political
correctness and uh and critical race
Theory and radical gender ideology into
into the pentagon's hallways itself so
we we need new leadership we need to be
building a military that's fitted to the
times that's also the best way to ensure
peace in the world always has been
always will
I like knowing exactly where my meat
comes from and with moink I know it's
coming from small Family Farms all
across the country white delivers
grass-fed and grass-finished beef and
lamb pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door Mike lets you
choose the meat delivered in every box
select an existing box or create your
own set your delivery Cadence and enjoy
delicious meat you can cancel anytime
but you won't want to if you're not sure
where to start check out their standard
box it comes with a little bit of
everything chicken ribeye burgers and
steak moink is all about supporting the
Family Farm think about it this way two
percent of Americans are farmers but 100
of Americans eat we need to show our
support for the families that keep us
well fed after receiving my first moike
box I was floored the salmon and chicken
are both fantastic and the steak might
be the best I've ever had and keep in
mind I cooked it myself with a freezer
full of moig products I can without a
doubt say it is a fantastic deal on a
ton of delicious and well-produced
products you won't be disappointed and
you can rest assured all of Mike's Meat
comes from wholesome American farmers so
keep American farming Going Strong by
signing up at moinkbox.com jbp right now
in Dr Peterson's listeners can get free
bacon in your first box and let me say
it's the best bacon you'll ever taste I
re-upped my subscription because I ran
out too fast Mo ink box.com jbp that's
moinkbox.com jbp
so your sense is that the best strategy
for dealing with Russia and also tell me
if I've got this right and also
simultaneously China is to bolster the
American Military to ensure that Russia
uh the the sufficient Aid is provided to
Ukraine to stop Russia in its tracks
that that sends the proper message to
China
that that would require further support
for the American Military and that
that's the best way to stop Russian
adventurism what do you think of
arguments that Russia had felt
threatened as a consequence of NATO
incursion into Ukraine and that a fair
part of this conflict emerged because
the Russians felt that they were being
encroached upon by
by the expansion of the NATO alliance
and and the potential inclusion of of
Ukraine into that domain I mean and you
know it's also the case that Putin
certainly has appealed to his people on
that front he's also told his people
that he is a buttress against the kind
of woke ideology that we've also
discussed and so
um while those are all and then the
third problem I suppose is that I'm
still concerned understanding your
argument I'm still concerned that
pushing the Russians into a corner where
they become dangerously weak heightens
the probability of let's say limited
exchange of nuclear weapons on the
battlefield so you said we we frighten
China we keep Russia at Bay
I'm concerned about the fact that the
Russians perhaps share some of the more
conservative Western views with regard
to the woke Nightmare and also that if
we push them into a corner they're more
likely to have an itchy nuclear trigger
finger
so well I I just honestly believe the
NATO argument the threat from NATO that
that's that's all just posturing by
Putin he's you carefully examine his
public statements for years Jordan he's
been very clear
uh that his ambition is to re-establish
what was the old Soviet sphere of
influence in Eastern Europe uh and so
there's I mean look the NATO has been a
a peaceful Alliance of the West uh
forged as it was in the aftermath uh of
World War II and uh uh and and I I uh I
think there's one reason and there's one
person to blame for the unconscionable
Invasion and War that's raging in
Ukraine today and that's Vladimir Putin
and we just simply need to hold into
account with with regard to the fact
that we never want to forget uh that
Russia is uh the second largest nuclear
power uh in the world uh I I believe we
we need to make it clear that our
military support uh for Ukraine is for
uh repelling the Russian invasion in
Ukraine and restoring their sovereignty
I think that it's absolutely essential
that the commander-in-chief of the
United States make it clear uh to the
Ukrainian military and our alliance how
far our support goes uh and and I think
that that uh that making it clear that
this is about re-establishing uh what's
been claimed and not uh not uh intruding
upon or uh attempting to uh uh you know
move into the Sovereign territory uh of
Russia is important and uh look it's uh
but this is this is statecraft this is
real and I I just have to hold view that
that uh
weakness arouses evil
but peace comes through strength and I
think that we by electing a new
president that understands that basic
principle that's able to Marshal the
support in the Congress to build a
military fitted to the Times by by
hastening the support if the war isn't
already over hastening the support of
the Ukrainian military to repel the
Russian invasion I think the world
quiets down very quickly and again I I
the the argument that I really reject is
people that say well the real issue in
the world today is China
oh okay I've met president G I've I've
been to China I I'm a student of China's
Ambitions I've met with all of our
allies in the region I understand uh
what China's up to
um uh and and how broad their Ambitions
are but I also believe that uh as you
can see the alliance has been forged
between G and Putin that that that XI is
looking very carefully at How the West
responds uh to Russia's attempt to
redraw International Lines by force and
while while it's continued its
provocations even over the last two
weeks with uh with with navy ships at
Sea uh in the Taiwan Straits and in the
air uh uh sending a message to them that
uh the Free World will not tolerate
redrawing International lines uh by
military force will will contribute
greatly to to um
um uh tamping down uh China's Ambitions
in the Asia Pacific
do you two questions then do you think
that
Putin respects Biden as a negotiating
partner and do you think that Putin
would respect you as a negotiating
partner and maybe why to both of those
questions
well I it would be hard for me to
believe that Putin or any leader around
the world
um
I I think they respect the United States
of America but I I don't know that they
uh that they respect the president of
the United States today at the at the
level that they should and and it just
comes from a series of steps by this
Administration
um well I mean to unilaterally reopen
nordstream 2 to Russia I mean it was it
was a policy of of appeasement on to
reverse one of the policies we'd we'd
put into effect made no sense at all to
to uh to attempt to get back into the
Iran nuclear deal
literally hat in hand begging uh the the
uh the the uh the mullers in in Iran to
come back to the table uh and
renegotiate uh until it it finally fell
apart was was just absurd uh and and uh
and of course the fact that we had
negotiated an agreement in Afghanistan
with the Taliban
that made it clear
that they were required
to work with the Afghan national
government never harm any military
personnel
and never Harbor terrorists those were
the three preconditions or we we made it
clear to them that we would hit them
harder than they'd ever been hit before
18 months went by in our Administration
in the early days of this one where
there was not a single American Casualty
in Afghanistan
Taliban new new we meant business
but in this Administration when we began
an orderly withdrawal which for some
incomprehensible reason uh got got
delayed uh into well after the fighting
season and if you recall President Biden
it was leaked that they were talking
about making the departure on September
11th uh which was incomprehensible to me
that we would Mark that date a date of
uh A Dark Day in American history the
source of which was launched from
Afghanistan for the withdrawal in any
event that he moved the date of
withdrawal he delayed it he gave the
Taliban the opportunity to reconstitute
but the initial failing
was when the when the when the Taliban
began to move their military in the
north into mazural Sharif and we did
nothing
uh I I think that's set into motion not
only the disaster that claimed the lives
of 13 American servicemen and women
courageous service men and women who
were standing at at the airport in
cobbled trying to save lives uh but I
actually I actually think it it set the
conditions for uh the Afghan National
Army to throw their guns down make no
opposition at all uh and since then
we've also confirmed and and at least in
one instant taken successful action
against them harboring terrorists once
again in Afghanistan but all of those
conditions I believe
May well I don't know may well have
contributed to Putin uh assuming that if
he rolled into Ukraine
that the same thing would happen
I mean you remember Joe Biden actually
actually was asked would would we get
involved if there was a Russian invasion
and he actually made reference if it was
a small invasion it would depend and and
then when when The Invasion began if you
remember the administration leaked to
the media that they'd reached out to
president zielinski who I know and
became familiar with
they reached out and said we'll send a
plane
like like uh like ghani who got on a
plane and got out of Afghanistan as soon
as things began to collapse and and in
words that I think will let go into
history president zielinski said we
don't need a plane we need ammunition
uh and and uh and and he squared his
shoulders and and uh and fought back
against the Russian invasion so all of
this when you say to me uh look I'm an
American I'm a patriotic American I love
our country the world respects the
United States of America but do they
respect our current commander-in-chief
at the level that they should I I I
would argue they do not okay so so the
second part of that question is you know
do you think Putin would respect you and
but I want to modify that question
slightly too because there must be a
Temptation at this level of intense
negotiation I suppose a psychological
Temptation also
to not be strong but to look strong
right and and you can imagine that a
weak man in a position of power will
fall prey to the temptation to look
strong and to therefore put forward more
force that is than is absolutely
necessary in an attempt to buttress His
Image and so I would like to know how
how it's best for leaders to protect
themselves against that Temptation so
you're if you became president you would
step into the hot seat huh in in that's
that's being heated up in many ways
simultaneously how do you protect
yourself psychologically against the
temptation to you know to to beat your
chest and be a strong man instead of
trying to
settle the situation internationally in
the manner that's best for everyone
going forward and and this this pertains
to the question of why Putin might
regard you as a respectable negotiating
partner so let me let me let you
elaborate on that
I mentioned Calvin Coolidge at the
outset of our conversation uh
in my announcement speech last week I
quoted Calvin Coolidge who said it's all
together a benefit to the country
uh uh and to the office holder where the
president does not consider himself to
be a great man
and I I can assure you
um
I'm never confused about that I'm an
everyday American I'm a small town guy
from Southern Indiana raised by a combat
veteran family living the American dream
but I look I I you you ask a very
profound question and I I go back again
to history that's what all my my
background was in college I was a
student of American History Teddy
Roosevelt I think said it well
that on the global stage America should
walk softly and carry a big stick
um that uh that I I you know I've I've
had uh I'd leave it to others to to
judge how my leadership would be
assessed but I I think I've got a
reputation for standing my ground I
think I think people know that my yes is
yes and my no is no
um the way that I would maintain that I
would I would tell you is for me as a
Christian believer is
a daily time and devotions and prayer uh
I'm someone that really
believes in uh in in investing time in
my faith to study and understand uh what
the Bible teaches about wisdom and uh
I've always sought to apply that in my
life but with regard to Vladimir Putin I
can tell you I've had a conversation
with him one-on-one
and it was at a International Conference
and uh we had a brief exchange and he
wanted a private moment together this
was in the year leading up to the
midterm elections in 2018 Jordan
we had a Polish either a fair number of
people around and this has been written
about and I wrote about it in my book
uh but as he began to engage me he had
an International Conference coming up
with President Trump and he asked uh you
know if I would convey a desire for
nuclear non-proliferation that we've got
to begin to talk about those things I
nodded and listened and then I looked at
him and I said standing just a couple of
feet away from him
I looked at him and said uh well Mr
President I have something I'd like to
say to you
and he said through Russian through an
interpreter he said
go ahead
and I said we know what happened in 2016
and it can't happen again
and with that he
sure he speaks perfect English with that
he feigned that he didn't understand
my statement and uh any and he turned to
his foreign minister lavrov who was
standing thereby and lavrov said in
English elections
I mean look in the 2016 election uh the
Russians did not interfere on behalf of
any particular candidate they interfered
across the board
it's what they do in Western countries
they they sow dissension and
misinformation and and we know for a
fact it happened and I'd said so
publicly
but so he turned back to me after lavrov
said uh elections
um and said uh through Russian he said
no that wasn't us we had nothing to do
with that that wasn't us and I I nodded
and said uh Mr President I'm very aware
of what your public position is on this
but I'm telling you we know what
happened in 2016 and it can't happen
again
at that point he uh
he Shrugged did a half nod and uh the
conversation moved on I mean that's
really really where it begins I think
between heads of state and I've been
able to represent the United States on
the world stage
um that wasn't a very private
conversation there were a lot of staff
on both sides there's pictures of it you
can find on the internet pretty easily
and there were reporters with an earshot
that wrote about that moment but I think
the the most important thing between
heads of state is that you have the
ability to look people in the eye and um
uh and and tell them what your
expectation is and make it clear where
the consequences will be uh even without
saying it and uh I I would tell you that
if I had the great privilege of being
president of the United States I'd I'd
look for friends all over the world for
the United States I'd look for
opportunities for peace but uh
you know I'd always uh I'd have one hand
extended in friendship
and the other hand resting comfortably
on the holster of the arsenal of
democracy uh so that uh those who are
enemies of Freedom around the world who
would threaten our people or threaten
our allies
um
I would know him uh America means
business
president Trump recently issued a
warning from his Mar-A-Lago home quote
our currency is crashing and will soon
no longer be the world standard which
will be our greatest defeat frankly in
200 years
there are three reasons why the central
banks are dumping the U.S dollar
inflation deficit spending and our
insurmountable national debt the fact is
there is one asset that has withstood
famine Wars and political and economic
upheaval dating back to Biblical times
gold and you can own any tax sheltered
retirement account with the help of
Birch gold that's right Birch gold will
help you convert an existing Ira or 401K
maybe from a previous employer into an
IRA in Gold when currencies fail gold is
a safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have protect your savings with
gold Birch gold has an A plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau and
thousands of happy customers text Jordan
to 989898 and get your free info kit on
gold again text Jordan to 989898
foreign
I know you have a heart out in an hour
um we have time for one more question
and so I'm going to ask you a follow-up
to something you just described me when
I met you and your wife and and when we
talked I did get the impression you know
that I I walked away from that
conversation thinking that that for for
what it's worth that that you struck me
as a man who could be trusted and I
already made reference to the fact that
I think you could bring a certain degree
of admirable normalcy to the insanity
that Reigns at the moment
but I would say in reference to the
great man issue you served for a long
while as the right-hand man of a man who
I think does style himself rightly or
wrongly a great man and and of course
the shadow of trump or the legacy of
trump hangs over you rightly or wrongly
why is it that you served with Trump for
so long why did you think that was in
your best interest his and the countries
and why do you now think that you would
make a better leader than your than the
former president
well first let me say I'm humbled by
your kind words
my respect for you is boundless and I'm
grateful for those words I'll share them
with my wife when we break
um
well first look uh when when I got the
phone call to join the National Ticket
or the a group of people being
considered for it um
I didn't expect it I'd actually endorse
another candidate in the primary in
Indiana but uh but Donald Trump had won
the nomination and for me
uh the prospect of Hillary Clinton
serving as president for eight years
following uh the liberal unfailed
governance of of Barack Obama for eight
years was an incredible threat
uh to the America that I had grown up in
I I thought if we if we put 16 years
of essentially a socialist agenda uh in
effect uh driving America toward a
secular European style welfare state my
my children and grandchildren would not
grow up in the America that I had grown
up in and so for me when the phone call
came I had one of two questions I that I
said I would I would need to have
answered number one we need to know them
better we didn't know uh either the
president or his family at all and
everything the pencils do we do as a
family
and secondly I said I'd want to know
what the job description was
uh because only one person gets to write
that job description every four years
for the vice president and so
um I mean my attitude was uh if if we if
we felt there was a rapport that we
could establish with them as a family
which we did almost immediately with
them
um but if I felt like a job description
would give me the ability to help the
country
uh first by defeating Hillary Clinton
and secondly by advancing a conservative
agenda
um uh I I was anxious to do that and
once he once he explained to me that the
role of the Vice President in his mind
would be an active role it'd be active
in the legislative process active in
even interviewing appointments to the
Supreme Court active around the country
promoting our policies active around the
world representing America when the
phone call came Jordan I said yes in a
heartbeat and I will tell you I'm
incredibly proud of the record of the
Trump Pence Administration I mean I mean
my old running mate promise to govern as
a conservative and we did
we cut taxes roll back regulation three
justices to the Supreme Court that just
gave America A New Beginning for life we
rebuilt our military created the first
new branch of our Armed Forces we
secured the southern border of the
United States of America and as you've
said many times in this conversation the
world was much more peaceful
and uh and and uh and Isis was destroyed
and uh the most dangerous terrorists in
the world was taken out it's all a
record I'm incredibly proud of
um in fact as I'll share again here in
North Carolina today I some people might
wonder why I'm running against my former
running mate
um in the wake of how proud I am of that
record some in this field are already
criticizing our record it's their right
to do that
um but I'll I'll battle them on that too
but for me it came down to the promise
that I made
when I took my oath of office
and the overall direction of the party
as I said in my announcement speech when
I raised my right hand I swore to the
American people and to almighty God that
I would support and defend the
Constitution of the United States
and on that fateful day January 6.
uh president Trump
um uh asked me to choose him over the
Constitution
but I thought my duty was clear and
still believe it was that I was I was
there under the Constitution to preside
over a joint session of Congress to open
and count the votes that have been
certified by the states reviewed by the
courts and would be debated in
objections in the Congress but our job
was to open and count no more no less
we did our duty that day I'll always
believe by God's grace to ensure the
peaceful transfer of power but the fact
that the president continues
to say that I had the right to overturn
uh the election
um uh animates me I I think I think no
one should ever serve as president of
the United States who puts themselves
over the Constitution of the United
States it's the oath we swear
and I'm going to take that case to the
American people but secondly it has to
do my candidacy is animated by my belief
in the conservative agenda something
that you've articulated in new and
renewed and fresh ways for individuals
and for the country and I'll always be
grateful for that but it's a it's an
agenda about American leadership in the
world I mean it's my old running mate
and others are backing away from
America's leadership I I want to lean in
I want to I want to rebuild our military
I want to make sure that we continue to
be the leader of the Free World when it
comes to uh fiscal responsibility Joe
Biden's policy is insolvency I mean we
have a national debt the size of our
nation's economy and Joe Biden won't
even talk about uh the entitlements that
represent 70 percent of the federal
budget and growing we are headed to a
debt crisis the likes of which the world
has never seen and Joe Biden refuses to
talk about it by my old running mate
refuses to talk about it I mean Joe
Biden and Donald Trump have the exact
same policy on entitlement reform and
many Republicans as well in this field
also shy away from talking about it I'm
going to talk about uh how we deal with
the national debt how we improve and
reform these programs and lastly my
commitment to the sanctity of Life I'll
always be grateful to have been part of
an Administration that appointed three
of the justices
the sent Roe versus way to the ash sheep
of History where it belongs but now in
this new season this new era for life
just at this moment when we can work to
expand protections for The Unborn
protections for women in crisis
pregnancies support for newborn
some in our party including my old
running mate are shying away from
standing firm out of a concern for its
impact on politics
um
I I don't believe that I believe if we
stand firm with compassion and principle
the American people will rally to our
cause but uh but even if they did not I
think the cause of life is the calling
of our time the sanctity of life
being restored to the center of American
law I think must remain an objective of
the Republican party and uh so for all
of those issues uh it's what brings me
to this fight but uh that was why I
joined the ticket to begin with and no
regrets no regrets I'm grateful for what
we did we're able to do for the country
uh I was I was sorry it came to the end
that it came to
but I'm absolutely convinced if we'll
keep our
party and our country on course of the
same policies that minted our movement
starting back in the days of Ronald
Reagan and going forward uh that will
restore this country we'll uh we'll
secure our nation America will be
stronger and more prosperous than ever
before
so help us God all right sir I'm I swore
to your staff that I would ensure that
this podcast lasted no longer than its
steam time and that was a really good
place to end I would say and so thank
you very much for taking the time to
talk with everyone who's watching and
listening today and with me it's a
privilege to be involved in the election
campaign in the manner that I am and I
certainly appreciate your time and
attention as I do appreciate the time
and attention of everyone who's watching
and listening and so perhaps sir
sometime in the future you've got a
whole year on the campaign Trail we can
sit down and have a further discussion
there were lots of other Pandora's boxes
that we could have opened but we covered
a fair bit of territory usefully today
and so once again I'd like to express my
appreciation for your willingness to sit
and talk with me I'll look forward to a
Jordan Peterson and God bless you for
your matchless voice
ciao everyone yep bye bye sir